we have always urged for a sensible deal
to be done
particularly with the northern ireland
protocol it always made it more easier
if we had a sensible deal in place
clearly we will want to see the detail
of the deal particularly around security
cooperation which of course is very
important to us in northern ireland
and data adequacy and things like that
but look this is good
news and we should welcome it as such
and now we look forward to moving
forward
in the joint committee as well to make
sure that we have
as least friction as we possibly can
i believe it is the least damaging and i
think it's very good news that we have
achieved a deal between britain and the
european union it's good for irish jobs
it's good for the irish economy
not harassed no quota free trade deal
between britain and the european union
it's got an aviation it's good in terms
of judicial police cooperation
uh energy and research and i think it
lays the foundations for
a more harmonious relationship into the
future now between the european union
and great britain
that's important to ireland because our
relationship with britain as our nearest
neighbor
is particularly uh important in the
context of the
transformation of that relationship over
so many years leading to the peace
process
and also a better type of relationship
and
myself and boris johnson have
recommitted against this morning to
meeting early in the new year uh to um
create a new strategic framework within
which we can develop that relationship
in a post-brexit world
that is important so i i'm very
hopeful now that the regions in
particular in ireland that would have
suffered the most
from an ordeal brexit can now develop
with some degree of certainty and
clarity because
businesses across the country needed so
just to summarize in the republic of
ireland they are hugely relieved
that those tariffs and quotas have
disappeared given that they export
13 billion euro of agri-food products to
gb
every year and in northern ireland
they're recognizing that this place now
becomes very attractive
to international investors from america
and the united
and the far east for example who may
want to be trading both into the eu
and into great britain